do some breath work and meditation and  if you're not getting there fast enough  you should try EMDR and if that doesn't  work try some MDA it's without the meth  part of MDMA and if that doesn't work do  MDMA if that doesn't work do ketamine  and I'm saying do this with a therapist  I did one of my podcast episodes I went  I got injected with ketamine at a at a  psychiatrist Clinic just to you know  talk about what it does like still out  there with ketamine all right maybe you  could try LSD and if it's not there okay  mushrooms problem with mushrooms is you  don't know what you're going to get and  then you would look at doing DMT then  5meo DMT and if you still haven't got  there then you hop on an airplane you  fly to Peru or somewhere where there's  someone who is taken  Ayahuasca on a daily basis for decades I  forgot the one after breathwork  meditation tantric sex you should do  that before you start going and doing  ketamine